because i would say it's it's all about
suspension the suspension of disbelief
right there's so many waifus that work
simply because they
are anime characters yeah and that's
that's what really works into
hey i can really [ __ ] love this
character and what she represents
but there's no [ __ ] way that she
exists in real life and i could
you know be with someone like that's the
exact reason why i'm okay with
made characters but i can't stand made
cafes
right like that you know what my [ __ ]
god going to a maid cafe
it's not the cringiest [ __ ] it's so
crazy
it is insane it is extremely cringy and
i just don't
understand like i don't mind the whole
like ghost in someone's thing like if
it's a [ __ ] fictional 2d character on
my screen saying yeah
but then when i went into a maid cafe
and a real-life woman
said that to me in the exact same way i
was like please stop yeah and then
i remember like peak mid-2000s like
cringe culture was all about like
seeing people act like anime characters
right in real life and i still like to
this day i still [ __ ] cringe
it doesn't translate whenever someone
tries to act like an anime character
and that's whether it's a [ __ ]
western fan or it's someone a japanese
mage you know
it never gets it could be the cutest
japanese girl it's still cringe
i think also being british and
australian where i think we're like our
social
rules are a lot more different to
america and japan yeah just anything
like that it's just
instantly instinctively uncomfortable
yeah yeah people
you're putting on an act and putting me
above you yeah right i think in real
life i
i think most people don't like it when
people
pretend to be anything other than a
human right yeah right right
i turn into you when you view youtubers
whenever like someone acts like an anime
character i'm just like
please act like a human being i know
you're not an anime character
like you you put a [ __ ] 3d model
let's go
that's it yeah put it put a 2d over top
fine is it the eye contact is it that
they have eyes
you can see their eyes and you can see
the [ __ ] it's like death in their
eyes
like please stop i can see it in your
eyes this is uncomfortable for both of
us
yeah because because every time i walk
into a maid cafe i know
they're not doing it because that's what
they really are like
right no because when you're a v tuber
there's a screen
there is there is a screen there's the
barrier you can't you cannot physically
interact with them you know what i mean
as a british person i get uncomfortable
when people smile
like when mcdonald's employees smile
like i that's how much i do not want you
to act you should not be happy working
at mcdonald's i worked at mcdonald's
and if you're smiling i'm like you don't
get paid enough to smile don't don't
smile
it's like it's like saying that your
favorite animal is a lion and you really
enjoy watching lions at a zoo because
it's from a distance but if you're in
the cage
this is such a weird but but if you're
in the cage with an actual while you're
like
i don't want to get it i don't want to
potentially death there there's in
mcdonald's i
when i'm there and they look at me and
they smile at me asking for my order i'm
like this is a lie
you you're not happy about receiving
money yeah i know you're not don't
pretend
right and there's because it's even that
that level of fakeness is uncomfortable
for them
especially in the uk right you'll never
see a [ __ ] mcdonald's employee smile
and when they do it like stop that
i'm watching yeah stop smiling right now
it's like watching a youtuber be really
nice
when you know they're an [ __ ] in real
life right it's like yeah
just stop me yeah